FOXX'S DECISION TO DROP THOSE 16
CHARGES AGAINST EMPIRE ACTOR
JUSSIE SMOLLETT.
MY NEXT GUEST WITH THE SUPPORT
OF THE MAJORITY LEADER
MITCH MCCONNELL IS PREPARING
INVESTIGATIONS INTO THE
POLITICAL BIAS AT THE FBI THAT
TARGETED PRESIDENT TRUMP.
JOINING ME NOW, THE HEAD OF THE
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE,
LINDSEY GRAHAM.
ALL RIGHT, SENATOR, THE THEME OF
REPERCUSSIONS, AND BOTH OF THESE
CASES, CAN WE EXPECT THE DOJ'S
FULL INVOLVEMENT?
>> YEAH, I THINK SO.
I THINK BULBAR IS IT -- BILL
BARR IS A MAN AT THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE, THIS HAS BEEN HIS
LIFE'S WORK AND I THINK HE'S
DISAPPOINTED AND CONCERNED BY
THE WAY THE FBI HANDLED
THE FISA WARRANT APPLICATION,
THE COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION, AND HE'S GOING TO
BE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF LOOKING TO
FIND OUT HOW THIS GOT OFF THE
RAILS.
>> Laura: A LOT OF FOLKS WHEN
THEY APPROACH ME AND I'M
TRAVELING ON THE COUNTRY, I'M
SURE YOU GET THE SAME THING.
PEOPLE SAY HOW DO HILLARY'S
PEOPLE MANAGED TO SMASH
BLACKBERRIES, UNMASK ALL THESE
AMERICANS WITH PROBABLY FOR
DUBIOUS REASONS.
THE U.N. AMBASSADOR UNMASKING,
SAMANTHA POWER.
HOW IS THIS ALL HAPPENING?
THERE'S NEVER ANY REPERCUSSIONS.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THEM ON THAT
SCORE?
>> ONE, LET'S FIND SOMEBODY TO
PROVE THAT IT DID HAPPEN THAT WE
ALL TRUST.
MUELLER, I STOOD BEHIND HIM
BECAUSE I THOUGHT IT WAS A FAIR
GUY COME A LOT OF PEOPLE ON OUR
SIDE THOUGHT HE WAS ON A WITCH H
SIDE THOUGHT HE WAS ON A WITCH N
SIDE THOUGHT HE WAS ON A WITCH .
I DIDN'T QUITE FRANKLY.
THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN
VINDICATED.
LET'S TAKE SOMEBODY LIKE MUELLER
TO ASK THESE QUESTIONS.
DID THEY GET A FISA WARRANT BY
USING COMPROMISED, BOGUS
INFORMATION?
>> Laura: THEY DID, DIDN'T
THEY?
>> I THINK SO BUT LET SOMEONE
OTHER THAN LINDSEY GRAHAM AND
LAURA INGRAHAM TO SAY IT.
LOOK AT THE OTHER SIDE OF THE
STORY.
IF THEY FIND SOMETHING, I WANT
TO BELIEVE IT BASED ON THE
EVIDENCE, NOT POLITICS.
>> Laura: IS BILL BARR LOOKING
INTO THE POSSIBILITY OF
APPOINTING ANOTHER SPECIAL
COUNSEL?
>> I AM URGING HIM FOR ONE CIVIL
REASON.
THIS IS AN EMOTIONAL EVENT.
MOST REPUBLICANS BELIEVE THEY
WERE OUT TO GET TRUMP.
MOST PEOPLE THINK THAT STRAW CAN
PAY JEN McCABE AND COMEY
WANTED CLINTON TO WIN AND TRUMP
TO LOSE AND THEY TOOK THE LAW
INTO THEIR OWN HANDS.
IF THAT'S TRUE, IT'S HORRIBLE.
LET'S FIND SOMEONE THAT CAN TELL
US IF IT'S TRUE, TAKE THE
APPROPRIATE ACTION.
I THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO
HAVE A MUELLER-LIKE FIGURE.
>> Laura: I KNOW THAT YOU
THINK SO BUT YOU'VE HAD
CONVERSATIONS WITH BARR.
YOU HAD DINNER WITH HIM THE
OTHER NIGHT.
IS HE APPROACHING THAT DECISION?
IS THERE A TIMETABLE IN WHICH
HE'LL MAKE THAT DECISION?
>> I THINK HE'S GOING TO LOOK AT
WHAT HAPPENED.
THE QUESTION FOR HIM, SHOULD IT
BE ME AND THE PROFESSIONALS HERE
INSIDE THE BUILDING OR SHOULD I
GET SOMEBODY OUTSIDE THE SYSTEM.
IT'S NOT A QUESTION OF IF HE
LOOKS.
IT'S HOW HE LOOKS.
>> Laura: WHILE, THEY ARE
ATTACKING HIM NOW.
THEY ARE TRASHING HIS
CREDIBILITY ON THE LEFT.
THEY ARE SAYING HE'S A POLITICAL
ACTOR, THAT MUELLER SHOULDN'T
HAVE TRUSTED HIM TO MAKE THE
OBSTRUCTION DECISION.
I'VE NEVER HEARD OF SOMEONE WHO
IS A BUSH ATTORNEY GENERAL --
EVERYONE IS ELEVATING THE BUSHES
NOW FOR A VARIETY OF REASONS.
I'VE NEVER HEARD ANYONE ATTACK
BILL BARR IN HIS PROFESSIONALISM
UNTIL THE LEFT GOT INTO THEIR
MULTIPLE STAGES OF GRIEF HERE.
>> LIKE ADAM SCHIFF HAS BECOME
THE NEW OLIVER STONE OF THE
HOUSE, THERE'S NOTHING THAT WILL
EVER SATISFY THEM.
BILL BARR IS ONE OF THE GREATEST
PEOPLE TO EVER SERVE IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE, HIGHLY
RESPECTED ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
AISLE AND TRUMP GOT TO BE
PRESIDENT.
THE POINT I'M MAKING IS LET'S
HAVE SOMEBODY THAT MAYBE WE CAN
FIND, LIKE MUELLER, TO LOOK AT
THE OTHER SIDE.
>> Laura: LET'S TALK ABOUT A
MAN WHO YOU PROBABLY WOULDN'T
RECOMMEND TAKE OVER THIS
INVESTIGATION.
JIM COMEY.
HE WAS ON NBC TONIGHT.
HE WAS LAST SEEN GAZING UP AT
THE REDWOODS.
HE WAS ON NBC TONIGHT
COMMENTING.
LET'S WATCH.
>> IF THERE ARE QUESTIONS THAT
HAVEN'T BEEN ANSWERED IN THE
HOURS AND HOURS AND HOURS OF
TESTIMONY I'VE GIVEN, OF COURSE
I'LL ANSWER THEM.
I WANT IT ALL DONE IN THE LIGHT
OF DAY.
NO MORE SECRETIVE POSITIONS.
PUBLIC HEARINGS TO SERVE THE
PUBLIC INTEREST.
IF THERE ARE QUESTIONS TO BE
ASKED ABOUT HOW WE HANDLE THIS
INVESTIGATION OR ANY OTHER, LET
ME KNOW WHEN YOU WANT ME.
>> Laura: HE'S READY.
>> OKAY, ONE IS GOING TO BE IN
PUBLIC AND I'LL GIVE YOU A HEADS
UP.
ONE OF THE QUESTIONS I'M GOING
TO ASK, DID BRUCE OHR TELL YOU
YOU SHOULDN'T TRUST CHRISTOPHER
STEELE AND HOW MUCH TIME AND
ATTENTION DID YOU PUT INTO
VERIFYING THE DOSSIER BEFORE YOU
CERTIFIED TO THE COURT THAT IT
WAS RELIABLE.
THERE YOU GO.
THINK ABOUT IT.
COME TO THE COMMITTEE SOON AND
GIVE ME THE ANSWER IN PUBLIC.
YOU WILL TESTIFY, MY FRIEND, IN
PUBLIC, NOT BEHIND CLOSED DOORS
AND YOU WILL ANSWER FOR YOUR
TIME IS FBI DIRECTOR.
>> Laura: I WANT TO GET YOUR
TAKE ON ANOTHER EVENT THAT
HAPPENED.
ONE OF YOUR FORMER COLLEAGUES,
SENATOR JOE BIDEN.
HE SEEMED POISED TO LAUNCH A
PRESIDENTIAL BID BUT LIKE A LOT
OF DEMOCRAT CANDIDATES, HE HAS
TO SAY THAT HE'S SORRY ABOUT A
LOT OF WHAT HE DID.
HE'S ATTEMPTING TO APOLOGIZE FOR
HOW ANITA HILL, MY OLD BOSS
CLARENCE THOMAS' CONFIRMATION
HEARINGS.
>> A BUNCH OF WHITE GUYS.
SHE FACED A COMMITTEE THEY
DIDN'T FULLY UNDERSTAND WHAT IT
WAS ALL ABOUT.
TO THIS DAY, I REGRET I COULDN'T
COME UP WITH THE WAY TO GET HER
THE KIND OF HEARING SHE DESERVE
DESERVED.
>> HE'S A GOOD GUY.
IF HE'S NOT PROUD OF THE LIFE
HE'S LIVED, WHY SHOULD WE MAKE
HIM PRESIDENT.
IF YOU REALLY HAVE TO APOLOGIZE
FOR MOST OF THE THINGS YOU'VE
DONE YOUR POLITICAL LIFE, WHY
SHOULD WE TAKE YOU FOR BEING
PRESIDENT?
>> Laura: I THINK HIS COMMENT
IS ACTUALLY RACIALLY CHARGED.
WHEN I SAY THAT, I THINK BY
SAYING IF IT'S A PANEL OF WHITE
MEN, YOU CAN'T BE FAIR?
THAT'S JUDGING SOMEONE BASED ON
RACE.
I THOUGHT WE WEREN'T SUPPOSED TO
DO THAT.
>> THE PROBLEM IS THE PARTY OF
JOE BIDEN IS DEAD AND HE'S
TRYING TO FIND A WAY IN THE NEW
PARTY.
IN THE NEW PARTY, YOU HAVE TO
APOLOGIZE BECAUSE IF YOU ARE A
WHITE GUY, YOU CAN POSSIBLY BE
FAIR.
THIS IS WHAT'S GOING TO UNDERCUT
HIM.
I LIKE JOE BIDEN.
I LIKE THE REAL JOE BIDEN.
I THINK HE'S BEEN WRONG ON
POLICY, BUT WHAT HE'S DOING NOW
IS PUTTING IN QUESTION WHETHER
OR NOT HE'S AUTHENTIC.
DO YOU REALLY BELIEVE HE THINKS
THAT THIS APOLOGY IS SINCERE?
IS HE JUST TRYING TO POSITION
HIMSELF FOR POLITICAL ADVANTAGE?